Von der Spitze des Stilfser Jochs stürzt sich
der deutsche Freeskier Benedikt Mayr ins Tal.
Rasant überwindet er 550 Höhenmeter,
gemeinsam mit seinem Südtiroler Freund
Markus Eder.
Mit akrobatischen Tricks überqueren sie die
Passstraße insgesamt 19-mal.
Die Dreharbeiten fanden bereits im Sommer
statt.
Das Video über die spektakuläre Abfahrt hat
er gerade veröffentlicht.
Das Schwierige war, dass es so unfassbar
steil war und wir so wenig Schnee hatten.
Das heißt, da war kein Spielraum für Fehler.
Man musste immer perfekt landen und gleich
den nächsten Schwung ansetzen, weil sonst
wär man ab- … ja, einfach ins Geröll rein und
bergabwärts gerollt.
Die Fahrt war drei Minuten, die Vorbereitung
knapp zwei Jahre.
Allein den Schnee mit Baggern und Raupen
so zu präparieren,
dass eine Abfahrt auf Skiern möglich ist,
dauert mehrere Monate.
Das Stilfser Joch: Der mehr als 2750 Meter
hohe Alpen-Pass,
der die Lombardei und den Vinschgau in
Südtirol verbindet,
ist der höchste Gebirgspass Italiens und eine
der extremsten Straßen der Welt.
Die Straße hat ’nen Mythos, weil sie so ist,
wie sie ist, und so gebaut ist, wie sie ist.
Mir war bei der Fahrt oben immer total
schlecht durch die ganzen Kehren
und irgendwie ist mir das im Kopf geblieben:
diese Straße – und hab mir gedacht, da muss
man irgendwann noch mal was machen.
Diese Herausforderung auf diesem extremen
Terrain schafft der 29-Jährige nur,
weil er über Jahrzehnte viele unterschiedliche
Erfahrungen im Schnee gesammelt hat.
Schon als Kind bewegt er sich trickreich über
die Pisten und entwickelt sich
zu einem der besten Freeskier Europas.
2014 tritt Benedikt Mayr bei den Olympischen
Winterspielen
in der neuen Disziplin Slopestyle an – als
einziger Deutscher.
Das Einzige was vorgegeben ist, war der
Kurs.
Und du kannst dich aber komplett selber frei
entfalten.
Also, du hast selber in der Hand, welche
Tricks du machst.
Ob du links, rechts rum, kopfüber, nicht
kopfüber drehst und ....
Ja, so, das ist ’n sehr kreativer Sport.
Durch das Regelwerk des neuen olympischen
Trendsports fühlt er sich bald eingeengt
und findet seine Freiheit in Island und in
Alaska wieder –
beim Freeriden durch unberührten Schnee
abseits der markierten Skipisten.
So ganz oben auf dem Berg alleine, ist schon
was Besonderes,
weil also ... Du weißt, das hat … so ’ne
Abfahrt, die gibt es wahrscheinlich nur hier,
in Alaska zum Beispiel.
Und das ist sehr, sehr aufregend.
Angsteinflößend auch zum Teil, weil die
Berge einfach sehr mächtig sind.
Aber die Angst auch positiv zu steuern und
für sich zu nutzen und zu sagen:
O. k., wenn ich merke, da hab ich jetzt Angst
davor, aber ich schau mal, ob ich’s probier.
Und, ja, sonst würd’s ja jeder machen, also
Angst ist immer dabei.
Benedikt Mayr macht es Spaß, die Grenzen
des Skisports immer wieder neu auszuloten.
Immer wieder denkt er sich neue und
extremere Formen aus,
sich durch den Schnee zu bewegen.
Und dokumentiert das in Filmen.
Man will ja nie immer dasselbe machen.
Die Fantasie bei dem Sport ist essentiell.
Weil ohne die kann nichts entstehen.
Und daraus entstehen neue Tricks, neue
Sprünge.
Jeder Mensch sieht einen Berg anders wie
[als] der andere.
Das Stilfser-Joch-Projekt war am Anfang nur
eine Idee im Kopf.
Und man musste sich vorstellen, wie so was
ausschauen könnte.
Dann bringt man es mal zu Papier.
Ja, und am Ende steht man dann da, und es
ist Wirklichkeit.
Und dann muss man es aber auch fahren.
Eine Fahrt mit Skiern über das Stilfser Joch
ist bisher einmalig
und sicher ein Höhepunkt in Benedikt Mayrs
bisheriger sportlicher Karriere.
Doch vor allem hat ihm die ungewöhnliche
Fahrt viele neue Ideen geliefert –
für neue Abenteuer im Schnee.